spider-man's far from home hasn't yet
swung on to theater screens for most
fans to see but the long-awaited Spidey
sequel premiered in Hollywood for
industry insiders and critics On June 26
the following day Marvel lifted its
embargo on far from home reviews and
outlets wasted no time publishing
critics initial reactions as of noon
eastern on the day the embargo lifted
far from home shined bright with a 92
percent approval rating on Rotten
Tomatoes that's well above the threshold
needed for a certified fresh'
distinction for the most part critics
are gushing about spider-man far from
home particularly for its quote breezily
unpredictable blend of team bromance and
superhero action as Rotten Tomatoes
itself summarizes it reviewers also love
that far from home quote stylish Lee
sets the stage for the next era of the
MCU by introducing characters like Jake
Gyllenhaal's Mysterio Danielle souls men
of soul Z at the movies gave the film
4.5 stars out of five writing that it
deals with the Avengers end game fallout
in a way that only this film can and is
able to close the chapter on one book
while laying the foundation for another
GamesRadar critic Jordan Farley called
far from home another home run for the
MCU that puts Pete's responsibilities in
a post Ironman world front and center
during a rib-tickling summer romance
whatever you do don't skip the credits
writing for Mashable Alexis Ned noted
that the Spider Man sequel wonderfully
follows up Avengers endgame and paves
the way for Holland's Peter Parker to
play an even bigger role in the MCU as
phase 4 begins far from home doesn't
waste an iota of the goodwill Marvel has
earned in its previous offerings every
cheeky nod towards Peter's future in the
MCU feels genuine even though the next
phase is still shrouded in mystery
spider-man far from home does a
fantastic job of latching the door that
end game closed while opening a whole
new universe of possibilities for Marvel
like Farley meds how did the importance
of the post-credits scene the Raps
Alonso do rod a noted that far from home
is quote an entertaining example of what
we used to call a summer movie thanks to
its playful romance between Peter Parker
and MJ I'm messing with you
thank you you're welcome you look pretty
too as well as Aunt May and happy Hogan
do radhe adds that it has steaks that
are about personal growth rather than
intergalactic Armageddon and some
satisfying hero on villain throwdowns
David Crowe at den of geek brought up
director Sam Raimi's original spider-man
trilogy in his review of far from home
writing that the flick is accepting of
Rama's legacy and incorporate some of
that high-flying iconography instead of
running from it he also gave kudos to
Gyllenhaal whom he thought played
Mysterio with quote wide-eyed intensity
there's a part of me that wants me to
tell you just turn around run away from
all this and then there's another part
of me that knows what we're about to
fight at Forbes Scott Mendelssohn wrote
that far from home is a quote robust
improvement upon homecoming at the very
least the film presents a Peter Parker
who was relatively good at his job and
doesn't consistently screw up to the
point where you wish he'd hang up the
costume before he kills someone that was
my biggest gripe with homecoming as the
film's Peter has to learn to be a hero
worthy of the Avenger stick turned him
into an MCU variation on Curious George
far from home offers more of what worked
last time and less of what didn't not
everyone felt the same way though as a
common criticism of far from home is
that it isn't as sleek as homecoming
despite being entertaining in its own
right USA TODAY's Brian Truitt was one
such critic writing far from home has a
lot more boxes to check than homecoming
in terms of storytelling and while it's
always enjoyable the film feels
unfocused in parts everything changes
when a major turn happens of the story
exploding can't talk about it at all
variety and the last half takes on a
very meta vibe with some of the craziest
visuals Marvel has unleashed in a while
and a stellar understanding of what
Gyllenhaal can do so well on screen
spider-man far from home has pulled in
some sour reviews to go alongside the
stellar ones I'm sorry I'm sorry doesn't
I understand
I just want to be like you and I want
you to be better Todd McCarthy at The
Hollywood Reporter called the film bumpy
with quote hokey and ill-judged
special effects ill motivated and less
than awesome action set-pieces and a
villain that isn't compelling enough the
New York Post's Johnny Ola sinski said
that far from Holmes action and logic
quote fall short of its awesome
predecessor while Pamela Powell of real
honest reviews kept things simple when
she called the sequel quote just another
formulaic superhero film even so the
general consensus is that the flick is
impressively charming fun funny and
totally rad judge for yourselves when
Spiderman far from home hits theaters
July 2nd check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite superhero
films are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]